[Music]
these novels that that you write are can
be over a thousand pages long
they're massive tomes and apparently you
you write them all on a computer but
unlike most authors you're not worried
about a computer virus I mean an author
who writes a thousand-page book their
greatest fear is a virus invades and
destroys a chunk of their book you don't
worry about that why no I have a secret
weapon I actually have two computers I
have the computer that I browse the
internet with and then I get my email on
and I do my taxes on and that computer
and then I have my writing computer
which is a DOS machine not connected to
the Internet
a das machine yes remember does I use
WordStar 4.0 and word-processing did you
make this computer out of wood I'm
curious why you decided to stick with
this old program well I actually like it
I mean it does everything I want a word
processing program to do and it doesn't
do anything else I don't want any help
you know I hate some of these modern
systems where you type up a lowercase
letter and it becomes a capital I don't
want a capital if I'd wanted a capital I
would have typed the capital I know how
to work the chef did you yell what about
spellcheck I bet you hate well so you
can't write actually when you have the
realm of orbit or yes
you would be constantly like and then
you know Lord Targaryen there's now a
Targaryen you mean
tire center no don't in tire center
Wow